Aaron Sampson here with a quick piece on
why you should be playing far cry 4 s
competitive multiplayer asymmetric
combat is a difficult thing to pull off
Splinter Cell spies vs mercs left for
dads humans verse in fected and the
upcoming evolve hunters verse monster
are a few games off the top of my head
that seem to have done a great job at it
now you can add far cry 4 to that list
with its competitive multiplayer titled
chronicles battles of kyra I'm not
saying this mode is perfect or doesn't
feel tacked on it really should have
just been another instance in world
rather than a separate menu and it's
loadout customization menu is kind of a
mess but far cry 4 is a strange beast
it's a game that when it fails i often
find the attempts kind of endearing or
even comical rather than frustrating
so back to asymmetric combat farcry 4's
multiplayer pits Golden Path fighters
with modern conventional firearms
vehicles and explosives versus the rack
just should reckon say rack from now on
the rack a bunch of drug-addled
speed-freak shamans who fire Bose ride
elephants craft potions and call in air
strikes when you throw these two forces
together in my two favorite modes
outpost and hunt for the demon masks
magic happens
starting without post basically base
defense the rack have to capture and
hold the village for a set amount of
time to win Golden Path holds up in
defense now normally I'd give it to the
rack but there's a twist at our players
will find familiar from the campaign
sits away from the main objective and
broadcast location of rack fighters at
all times so even though they can cloak
when crouch they still show up on the
minimap teams war for the tower as much
as the main objective in crafty Golden
Path players will mine or booby trap the
tower crafty rack fighters on the other
hand will grab an elephant and stomp the
crap out of Golden Path players coming
to set the tower back up or use
teleportation arrows and stab people in
the back it's the balancing act of
prioritizing the tower with the main
capture point that makes this mode so
chaotic and so much fun in the mass
capture mode on the other hand speed is
king and the Golden Path fighters have
vehicles glorious vehicles to run over
rack fighters run over to objectives and
did I mention running over rack fighters
all that never gets all that rack on the
other hand harvest red plants and get
high as balls then run at superhuman
speeds and that's pretty much it you
just left the two sides loose an
asymmetric warfare creates chaos in the
middle far cry 4 may be rough around the
edges but the sandbox is so worth your
time oh and did I mention there's a map
editor on console you can even make your
own crazy sandboxes air now
you
you